denisot d'abord avec la décision
surprenante prises par air france hier
soir de suspendre la location de 13
boeing 737 qui devait remplacer les
caravelles cette décision de la
direction est motivée par la prise de
position des syndicats de navigants qui
refusent le pilotage à deux admis par
les 55 compagnies qui utilisent les 737
alors que va-t-il se passer réponse de
jean pierre qui tarde voici la réponse
de jean pierre qui tarde donc sur ce
problème du remplacement des caravelles
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
navigants s'oppose à la direction
mais cette fois le conflit risque à
terme de remettre en cause le
développement même de la compagnie
nationale dans les années a vu ce qui
est en cause c'est la composition des
équipages qui feront voler le boeing 737
le 737 vous le savez c'est l'avion qui
doit remplacer les caravelles à partir
de 1979
cet appareil a été conçu pour être
piloté à 2 or les syndicats de navigants
pilotes mécaniciens veulent sur ce type
d'appareil et sur les autres à venir
bien sûr un équipage à trois deux
pilotes et un mécanisme non répond la
direction d'air france cela nous
obligerait à modifier le poste de
pilotage ce qui augmenterait les coûts
d'exploitation d'environ un million de
francs par an et par appareil
l'argument mis en avant par les
navigants pour l'équipage à trois c'est
la sécurité en pilote mieux et plus
sûrement à 3 k2 distille argument
contesté par la direction d'air france
encore une fois qui précise que 94% des
avions de ce type sont pilotés à 200 que
la sécurité des vols soit remise en
cause ou même menace
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui chacun
semble rester sur ses positions et
apparemment veut s'y tenir si personne
ne cède 6 comme par le passé on ne
trouve pas au dernier moment un
compromis et bien hier françois nom sera
purement et simplement au boeing 737 et
comme elle n'aura plus de caravanes
d'ici 1980 et bien la compagnie
nationale risque de manquer d'avis bref
ce sont tous les efforts fournis depuis
deux ans dans le plan de redressement
qui risque de pâtir de ce nouveau
conflit où le corporatisme parfois
dépasser des navigants reste plus actifs
que jamais